he's a Rich Eisen NFL Network host and
host of the Rich Eisen show he joins us
on the program
good morning rich how are you EP how are
you sir I'm doing okay now do you want
to start with the Michigan conversation
[Laughter]
deep down you're a Buckeye dad deep down
if you strip it down and it's red I
understand you've got the gritty veneer
of journalists understand but deep down
strip it all down yeah that's a scarlet
and gray heart that beats in that chest
is it dad
yeah I'm really really deep down yes I
know I understand but it's still there I
mean it's still there
I mean I understand like I said you've
you've lacquered on many layers of
coverage lead-ins highlights scores
interviews hard-hitting interviews
journalism yeah but deep down deep down
we're not in the press box here we're in
your living there is no cheering gate
Michigan Ohio State or Michigan against
somebody else not even Ohio State you
still beat ok heartfully for the scarlet
and gray right what would it take for
you to admit yeah you need to make a
change a lot of alcohol and a lot of
alcohol case oh you're going down with
Harbaugh no matter what of course
ok of course of course the guys had
forgotten out of coach he hasn't
forgotten out of recruit here I don't
know what's happening I have no idea
what's happening they don't have a great
quarterback like true you need a
pro-style look at Ohio State they got
Haskins in the NFL and John Enfield's is
going to end up in the NFL as well yeah
Michigan is Shields comes from Georgia
he plays three games and he's already
Ohio State's I mean you know look here's
the deal
okay Michigan does not have a B
quarterback the line play has been just
substandard it was surprising to say the
least as was the preparation coming out
of a bye week that was a shocking loss a
shocking loss a disappointing loss a
gutting loss Wisconsin fans deserve to
have
all the the smack-talk in Michigan's
direction they deserve it there's no
retort on retort 'less there's nothing
to be said except that if Michigan does
plant its foot and used it as a pivot
point and get better play much better
play from everybody especially the
quarterback position they could still
you know win their side of big ten and
have a shot at avenging themselves
against Wisconsin but that's a pipe
dream right now there's just no other
way to describe that based on the
performance they just had all right
how's that that's fine I mean it's you
know it was such a blowout Dan it was
such a blowout I did not receive a text
from the back row telling me how close
the game was on seed now let me just
describe this scene for your
listenership cuz I I went down this road
on my show
deep deep a deep dive on this on my
program and I also sent you the whistle
blower report dan in real time that you
did I don't know if you passed along to
your listenership but I'm sitting there
at my kids soccer game following along
the Michigan army exploits on my phone
which was down to about one to two
percent of battery and I had a couple of
friends of mine because it was difficult
to reload the app that I was falling on
I'm like hey text me some updates we
please and I boned buzzes just as I got
had just gotten a text that the kid was
about to kick the field goal for army to
maybe win it in regulation and it's Todd
Fritz saying something along the lines
of Titan the big house and I'm like what
do I do with that what do I do with that
Dan I know I say to you what do I do
with that you know what you do you you
you just brush it off you don't let
somebody say you know you don't let
somebody say that you're overrated as
hell or something like that you just
move on here's what I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna keep it in my back pocket
there's gonna come a time when the
Broncos are relevant again
and there's gonna come a time when the
Broncos are relevant again and they're
there they're losing to an opponent
they're supposed to beat it's gonna be
tight and mile high and I can I might I
might already have that Texas
speaking of overrated you know the Rex
Ryan comment with Baker Mayfield I know
and I played this a couple of times and
I said well Rex is doing what you want
now it's a hot take and you have a
bulletin board material to say Baker
Mayfield overrated as hell you know the
subtext like what he was saying I
thought he was actually saying some
things that were accurate about Baker
Mayfield how did you take that whole
exchange you know what it's interesting
because I try not to look we've had many
people have great broadcasting careers
after for instance say not speaking to
the media right so you can't blame you
can't sometimes color a person's
analysis based on what they did in their
career until certain occasions you know
as a as a jet fan loved Rex making the
team relevant right out right off the
bat almost taking them to the Super Bowl
but it's it's it's an interesting
message maybe a correct message just a
very wrong messenger I mean somebody
talking about being overrated or having
writing checks with their play doesn't
cash I mean are you kidding me yeah I
mean the only thing that's missing is
Mayfield saying that he wasn't going to
kiss Roethlisberger's rings right I mean
that's the only thing that's missing
here so it was difficult for me to
swallow from the messenger you can
actually hear the message okay now
that's fair I just thought that Rex I
think everybody's reaction was similar
to yours like well who's Rex Ryan to be
talking about anything that has to do
with offense right I mean but but but I
mean you talk to anybody who played for
Rex on the defensive side of the ball mo
talked about his diamond-like mind in
terms of getting quarterbacks off the
spot you you know know
quarterbacks weaknesses so I'm not I'm
not going to just throw it throw it all
out the window but you know obviously
this this is raised to another level
because Mayfield responds to it and the
number of times that he hears what
people say and respond to it and goes
ahead and elevates it it just makes no
sense to me it makes no sense to me
maybe it's because he say I'm I'm Chi
I'm I'm you know puffing my chest out
and showing the trolls that it doesn't
bother me but the trolls actually love
being heard and having it acknowledged
by the person they're calling out it's
it's it's you're you're feeding it as
opposed to trying to address it I'm
right there with you i if I'm Baker just
shut up just play but they can't the
Brent Freddie kitchens you know hey
write whatever you want to write blame
me but no you don't have to feed the
media here just go out and do your job
you know coach engine has only a couple
you know the the right what you want to
write card the I can take it card can be
played by a coach and I think he played
it at inappropriate time the problem is
is when you play it and then the results
don't change you can't play that card
again it might be helpful though for him
to communicate right off the bat to his
locker room that I'm willing to take the
heat for stuff that we all know in film
session you should be taking him for
that might be helpful we'll see what
happens against the Raven yeah I
understand that
McLovin McLovin dropped this bomb in the
first hour of the show his Aaron Rodgers
still a top-five quarterback number so
my rich these Packer fans man they're
piling on they're coming after me I go
you just ask if Aaron Rodgers says
top-five quarterback well in terms of
history
he is not in the top five statistically
but once somebody breaks the huddle in
the crucible of a game and looks over
the defense and figures out what to do
pre snap and then post snap it breaks
down and figure out what to do then and
take the the frying pan out of the fire
and actually hit the defense over the
head with it I'd say he's top five yeah
there's no discussion on this but you
know we were oh wait a minute wait a
minute I got it now though dad the
system is performing well yard
McLovin do you want to respond too rich
about your dough no no because I I used
to think that all quarterbacks could
play well under Jim Harbaugh so I the
system doesn't work
Wow back rovers Rich Eisen it's a great
media beef going on right now you just
need to text me that it's too far we're
we're too far down that road there I'll
leave you with this is this a must-win
for the Eagles tilling to win the
division I will say that yes you want to
win this division I do not see I do not
see that Cowboys losing five I see the
Cowboys better than eleven and five I
see them twelve and four I even see them
thirteen and three it's even better
yeah so three losses to win this
division is feasible and you best not do
that in your first four but to make the
playoffs as a wild-card team I'm I'm not
saying that's must-win for the Eagles
tonight but but this division appears to
be Dallas's and certainly if they lose
week for their third loss that that
would be a tough one who's on the
program coming up starting at noon oh I
got Tony Boselli who's on the game I was
doing the game for Westwood One and I
can't wait to talk to him about that
rare baby back flu thing that Jalen
Ramsey's got going on and in
Jacksonville but that's what we call
rare triple lindy right there the
wrestler Cody
in the comedian Gary Owen and obviously
phone calls and more Thank You bud hey
great to talk to you thank you but
that's Rich Eisen NFL Network host and
host of be a Rich Eisen show for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]